35 now las vegas restaurant week is back
in the valley right now
it's that annual event of course that
helps three square food bank and this
year
it actually helps the restaurants as
well bianca holmen live this morning at
three square with how we can all take
part
and save our appetites to do so bianca
good morning
hey good morning john so when you have
breakfast at rooster boy cafe and maybe
have some of their granola
on yogurt or even one of these amazing
croissants
you can help another family out there
who's in need have breakfast as well so
this is a great
call it's been happening for about 12
past 12 years and i'm joined here by
chef
sonya so you got the breakfast we got
the tarts and the croissants
correct you've also got lunch you're
serving yes we're doing
um a lunch that serves a duck confit
salad that i'm going to make right now
and then you get a dessert you pick a
tart beautiful and you've got to look at
these tarts they've got the
is this chocolate mousse and blueberries
no it's a blueberry cream cheese
and then we have a double chocolate with
salt maldon salt and then
blueberry almond sorry wonderful well
before sometimes you can have breakfast
first but she's going to go ahead and
prepare this amazing duck confit
salad i see cucumbers cucumber arugula
tangerines and tomato i made
a mustard vinaigrette with balsamic
vinegar i'm just going to pour that
a little bit on top
[Music]
a little maldon salt black pepper
and i'm gonna put a little bit of the
duck fat in there
[Music]
and we're just gonna toss it i'm gonna
put it right here on this
nice platter i found here
this looks so amazing and it's so good
that when you're eating good
you will be able to help another family
eat good as well across the valley again
so many people are food insecure right
now that means they don't have access to
great food options and when you dine out
during restaurant week
a portion goes back here to three square
and they're able to help serve so many
families we saw the long lines during
the pandemic you saw them
lines down the street for people who
needed those food baskets and we were
putting food into their cars and things
like that
well that's still happening so tell us
is it all done that's it
looks good it's simple and easy and it
is good it's really nice
i mean how does it feel knowing that
again when somebody eats this
you're going to help a family in need i
think that's everything isn't it like we
have to help each other i mean that's
really what it's about
at the end of the day and of course
rooster boy cafe they were helping
neighbors in need you all turned into a
store so
all great options they got the granola a
bagel
we got there's so much that rooster boy
cafe is doing yeah yeah that's the other
one exactly
so again go visit them they're they're
opening today yeah today from 8 30 to 2
30 we open wednesday through sunday
all right so perfect go ahead and have
breakfast at rooster boy cafe
and know that you're helping a neighbor
in need across the valley back to you
guys in the studio
oh my gosh bianca such such a good cause
obviously but that food looks so good
we are so hungry now to get your
appetite going